-Guys, big news today.
Our friends over at Ford
announced that they're
partnering
with Oracle Red Bull Racing
to return to the Formula 1
racing circuit.
This is giant.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is massive.
And just -- just thinking
about it
got my competitive juices
flowing.
So, with the help of Ford,
I decided to challenge
one of the world's
top Formula 1 drivers
to a race on a go-kart track.
Check it out.
-Hey guys, I'm here
at RPM Raceway in New Jersey,
and I'm joined by the boss
at Ford, Jim Farley.
Now Jim, tonight,
I'm going to be racing
one of the top Formula 1 drivers
in the world,
Sergio "Checo" Pérez.
-Huge.
-I'm a little nervous.
But before we get into that,
I want to talk about Ford
coming back
into Formula 1 racing.
-We haven't been in Formula 1
in 20 years, but --
and we're going back.
And racing's gotten huge.
Formula 1's gotten huge
in the US,
and we want to use it to promote
our electric vehicles,
so it's -- it makes sense
for us.
-And you've got
a good team, too.
-Well, we're going to join
Red Bull.
Like, they've been world
champion for a couple times.
-You got Red Bull.
You got a good team.
-Oh, yeah.
It's perfect for us.
-Of course, you would do this.
-You know, 'cause some CEOs
are into golf or tennis.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Or yachting.
But I like racing.
[ Laughs ]
-Now Jim, you were a racer
yourself.
Last year, I got to visit you
in Detroit.
You took me out for a spin.
It was so much fun.
I loved every single minute
of it.
I was kind of a natural,
is what I heard a lot of people
saying...
-Yeah, you were. Totally.
-...as I was driving by.
I handled it very well.
-Yeah.
-Racing is in my blood.
-But tonight's serious.
There's a lot at stake here.
Pride is on the line.
-Yes.
-So, you have agreed
to help train
to get me ready for the race.
-I think you are, like,
the ideal candidate
to beat the best
Formula 1 drivers in the world.
You're perfect.
-Thank you.
Are we -- Did we get that
on tape? Did we record it?
Because that is -- Finally
someone's saying that.
-Yeah.
♪♪
[ Engine roars ]
-First thing we have to do
is visualize yourself
behind the wheel.
-Okay.
-So, close your eyes.
-Yep.
-And then steer the wheel.
That's it, yep.
So, you're racing right now.
And then you're pressing
the throttle.
Press the throttle,
press the throttle.
And then don't forget
honking the horn.
Got to honk the horn.
Yeah.
-This is going to help me
win the race?
-No, actually,
it's for my TikTok.
♪♪
[ Engine roars ]
-Okay, Jim, it's time to drive.
These things are electric.
They've been hooked up to an
F-150 Lightning all day long.
-So, that's means
they're going to go really fast.
So, let's go take a lap.
-Let's do it.
♪♪
Wait for me!
Dude, this thing is awesome.
My gosh.
Whoo!
-Good job, Jimmy.
-This is like
real-life Mario Kart.
Oh, my gosh.
♪♪
[ Tires screech ]
-All right, Jimmy,
I think you're ready.
It's time to suit up.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, Checo.
-Jim, how are you doing?
-Ah, good to see you.
Pretty -- Pretty exciting
to have one of the best
Formula 1 pilots
in the history of the sport
here in the United States.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What's up, dudes?
What's up, Checo?
-Nice suit.
-Yeah, I was trying
to do something
a little more aerodynamic.
-Oh.
-I'm going to go get changed.
[ Engine roars ]
-Okay, gentlemen,
here to officiate the race
is Christian Horner,
the boss of the back-to-back
world champions
Oracle Red Bull Racing Team.
-Oh, thank you.
And look, guys,
we want to have
a good clean race.
Keep it nice and clean
out there.
No bumping, and no banging.
But go out there, have some fun.
And good luck.
And may the best man win.
-Let's go and race.
-I heard you took a DNA test.
Turns out
you're 100% that bitch.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Let's go!
♪♪
[ Engines whir ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You don't want to
mess with me, dude!
♪♪
Oh, my God,
I got air on that one.
♪♪
Slow down, Chec.
I'm in the lead.
I'm in the lead!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, yes!
[ Slow-mo ] Yeeeees!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] Yes!
Whoo! Whoo!
Jim, we did it!
Whoo!
Dude!
We did it!
We did it.
[ Laughs ]
Yes, yes!
-Good job.
That's for you.
-The winner.
-Champion!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My thanks to Jim Farley,
Christian Horner,
Sergio "Checo" Pérez,
and all of our friends
over at Ford and Red Bull.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight show," everybody.
Come on.